today we're going to be speaking with
philip devine who is
founder of riveted games the company
behind the new game
crypto blades which we will be talking
about uh we will also be talking about
nfts non-fungible tokens philip it's
really great to have you today
yeah thanks for having me david so okay
to start with
nfts i'll give you my understanding of
this and then you tell me all the ways
in which it is either wrong incomplete
or maybe by by some chance correct
the idea of an nft is you can
take an item uh of which there could be
many copies so for example i make a text
file on my computer and i put this is
the original david pakman text
file where i put my name and birthday
and then that file could be copied
endlessly you could have such a file on
your computer and and so on and so on
and it would be very difficult to know
like which is really the original file
the nft technology allows me
to definitively connect my
real text file with my name and birth
date
to one of these non-fungible tokens and
thus
there would be no doubt as to the
authenticity of the text file and then
that is something which could in theory
be traded purchased or sold am i close
at all
yeah that's exactly it and i'll i'll
kind of uh add to that just a little bit
um because i think people are at least
at this point fairly familiar with
cryptocurrency in general uh and they
know that there's some relation between
nfts and cryptocurrency and the way that
i kind of
equate it back to uh a cryptocurrency
that people know of like bitcoin
is um uh you can think of a of one
bitcoin kind of like a a block
of uh gold okay and if you cut that
block of gold in half
you have kind of two halves of the same
value but
you have maintained the same total value
of that cryptocurrency
however nft cannot be uh
cut or split its ownership is
is not split um between people
it is a simple uh transfer of ownership
a kind of an all or nothing type deal
that way it it uh maintains that
sort of certificate of ownership on the
blockchain what's the
appeal of this in the sense that this
has been exploding we've seen
tweets used with so bought and sold with
with nfts is that was there a
missing piece to some market
or thing people wanted to do for which
nfts are the solution
or is this something that's sort of been
created and now people are figuring out
how to monetize it
yes so um a brief history so
uh it started actually with something
called crypto punks
and just a a hobby kind of uh
experimental project
that was put out there where uh someone
took
uh randomly generated images of of these
you know kind of punk-like uh avatars
and um encoded each pixel
into the transaction uh making
these sort of tradable except they were
made out of if i
remember correctly bitcoin or another
alternative token
um and you had to manually decrypt this
data
to get these 64 bytes of color to show
the images
and then they thought well you know
wouldn't it be great if we created a
standard
so there's the erc 721 standard the
technical term but all that means is
um you can take a uh
a url of that points to somewhere
sure and say this is the actual full
you know 4k resolution uh you know
image or video or what have you and
now we can actually just kind of link
out to that
image and instead only store
the uh ownership information
on the ledger so to speak and so
um it's kind of evolved into well how
high resolution art can we
uh can we you know send people or can we
put on the blockchain
uh it's gonna be turning into a million
different things i think it's confusing
for people
because they say well if i create a meme
um
and then i turn i put it on blockchain
why can't someone else just take that
exact same meme
and put and also put it on the
blockchain yes why is that
why is that important and they're kind
of um
not necessarily seeing uh the long-term
benefits of this proof of ownership
and of what can all be uh placed on the
blockchain outside of just memes or art
so what are i mean we'll talk about the
the the gaming space because
that then is relevant to crypto blades
so maybe i'll ask this in
other than the gaming space what are
other of the most interesting
use cases that you see i mean like the
idea of you can
you can buy someone's original tweet
which is like well anybody can look at
it so what
is that interesting to buy like jack's
original tweet yeah i don't know
outside of gaming what are some of the
most interesting implementations and use
cases of practical value that you see
so um a practical value
you could technically uh store contracts
on the blockchain and then you could
automate
um the transfer of
titles of deeds um through
smart contracts which is another you
know hot topic
and um and that that would directly
translate into for example the financial
sector or the real estate sector
um uh another really interesting project
uh not exactly gaming related is
nba top shots i don't know if uh people
are familiar with that but essentially
what they have done is they've stored
what they call moments
on uh on the blockchain and these
moments
are essentially clips where you actually
own
the broadcasting rights to these moments
when you own
these uh top shot moments and um so
there's like an intellectual property
component essentially
a yes exactly so there's an intellectual
property as well as
the previous you know real property um
that are you know those are in effect
and currently being
used with nft technology is there
i mean you could imagine a situation
where for example wills
are sometimes contested someone dies and
they have a will
and the will is contested and it goes
through a probate process and you know i
mean it's eventually resolved it's not
it's not a great process uh for for many
of the people involved often
um could there be some way in which
nfts could authenticate i mean i guess
it depends on whether the problem is
whether people believe it's the real
will
or just are arguing about its contents
but is there something there with will's
trusts and estates
so in a smart contract
uh which is where the nfts essentially
live on
um those have all the different kinds of
rules for
how an nft would get transferred or the
different functions that you can perform
with an nft
and those are are are pre-programmed by
people who develop those smart contracts
and the fuzzy area with law
is we already have uh statutes
and and laws that are in books and when
lawyers come to
a courthouse they are contesting
whether or not a certain specific
scenario fits
on this side of the law or on that side
of the law and so
um i would love to see how uh
someone might you know kind of delve
into that problem using blockchain
and from what i can see i can see it as
as being
a fairly difficult area because
the rules are constantly being updated
and changing and the blockchain does
support things like that with
um things like oracle's which is uh i
won't get into 100 right now but
um there's just so many so many ways
that you know you can
incorporate real life into uh blockchain
technology so let's now jump into nfts
and and the gaming space i mean maybe
this is a good time to to get back in
and talk a little bit about cryptoblades
what what is crypto blades the game and
then maybe tell us
how nfts are going to be part of it sure
so crypto blades is essentially uh an
nft crafting
uh role-playing game where you can
create a character
which is actually an nft and then you
can craft different weapons which also
live
in the game as nfts and one of the main
benefits of this
is unlike um you know a game like world
of warcraft
blizzard owns uh everything that you
have worked for essentially and if you
wanted to transfer it or trade it you
know there's all kinds of different
limitations
there's all you know user agreements and
things like that where
they really don't want you to be able to
do that whereas
we want to tie in ownership of
this experience and of these items to
the player
using nfts and secondly we're really
trying to expand on
the utility of nfts meaning
uh you can store like i mentioned all
kinds of information
on an nft token and for example we store
the rarity we store uh how powerful a
weapon is we store
the level of your characters and all of
those can
uh essentially enhance your ability to
earn
uh skill tokens which these tokens are
much like
you know dogecoin or uh bitcoin
uh and and can be traded that there's an
active market for skill tokens
um right now so uh you are essentially
playing
to earn skill tokens and be able to
trade
all of these items and characters for
fiat currency if you wanted for
other items if you wanted uh for any
other currency
if you wanted so now what i i remember
friends that i never played warcraft
growing up but i have many many friends
that did and they would often say i
either sold or bought a character i've
been working on
now the the difference here is that that
was all fine and good
for as long as the game developer was
okay with you doing it and transferring
the the character for example but that
in theory that could be shut down at any
time whereas here you're actually
building it into the framework
yeah exactly um and that's the whole
idea
behind decentralization in general it's
a term that's
that everybody's familiar with but again
don't they don't always see
just the depth of that and by making
this decentralized
we're essentially saying look we're not
going to be in charge of
who owns what character who owns what
sword i'm
there's no possible way that i could
steal even though i made the game
there's no possible way i could steal
maybe a really
great item or even create this really
great item for myself
and so because of that it just it brings
in
this multi-user
decentralized and multi-user validated
uh kind of level of trust to this system
which is the entire
premise of blockchain in general is
establishing
trust so um what what's the timeline for
the game
and who's who's working on the game you
guys have an interesting team as well
yeah sure so uh the game will actually
be uh be released version one at the end
of this month
um we already have our skill token which
people can uh
actively purchase and buy on our website
uh at cryptoblades.io
um our team so i am my name's philip
devine as you know and uh
i'm the owner of riveted games and so
we've been working on
games in general published on steam uh
won many awards um through riveted games
and uh my partner daniel karsai um
he's been working with us since the
inception um
and uh kyle kemp is one of the he's our
front end developer he is
honestly one of the highest regarded
github users
uh out there right now he's worked on
hundreds of different projects
um and ray hammerling uh same thing he's
just a great open source developer that
we found uh we
we wanted people who are uh exceptional
at creating
open software because that's one of the
main uh
uh one one of the main benefits of
blockchain
in general is establishing trust and uh
and creating kind of open uh an open
society in a sense
so what often when games are released
then it's that's it the game is out
sometimes there's patches sometimes
there's expanded
content or whatever the case may be this
is sort of a different type of project
with implementation of nfts and other
things what happens
after the initial game release that you
guys plan to keep working on
sure so there's lots of features that we
want to build into the game
we also are building in a certain kind
of governance to the game which means
people who own skill tokens will
actually be able to vote
on what features they want to see in the
game most
and so our own players will have a a
smart contract which
will determine how we end up
building out the game in the future with
all kinds of different features and
things like that
what do you think is likely to change
bigger picture and game development over
over the next five to ten years will it
be based on technological changes or
will it be based more on
changing the kind of environment and
market around which games are kind of
introduced sure um well i think the
biggest thing around games in general is
going to be about digital
ownership so um you know it's been
around for i would say
it's it's gotten big since uh
collectible card games have been made
digital
and players would purchase these
collectible cards and
they want to make sure that uh no one's
going to be able to take them away from
them
because they've spent all this money
same with micro transactions people are
spending money on games
but not being given the assurance that
they will have those
uh either commodities or uh or art or
whatever
for their own enjoyment or you know and
if they don't want it anymore
they need to have a way to be able to
transfer that ownership
built in in a trustless way and i think
that's something that you know you'll
see
either blockchain be the primary driver
of or blockchain being
a um you know kind of just a secondary
option
that almost every game company is going
to have to adopt
in order to keep their user base what uh
what a time to be alive as i like to say
yeah definitely we've been speaking with
philip devine who's the founder of
riveted games the company behind
the new game crypto blades philip really
appreciate
your time today yeah thanks a lot
appreciate it